i i said on my channel people were like
mad at me because i said i think you
should stay in shape for your husband
and i think no i swear that like i think
you should stay in shape for your
husband and i think it's disrespectful
to get overweight like if you're in a
marriage and i'm not saying like you're
obviously your body's gonna change with
kids like if you just completely let
yourself go and get obese i'm like that
is disrespectful to a guy because you're
you're like you represent him yeah and
like people were so mad at me for saying
that because i'm like fellas you don't
have to take this [ __ ] leave the whales
yeah leave them i'm not talking about
girls that are trying i'm talking about
girls that get fat oh yeah and aren't
doing anything about it and have no
intention to ever do anything about it
like yeah girl what do you expect yeah
it's pretty ridiculous but those women
just don't care how their husbands view
them like their husband is probably an
accessory because if they genuinely were
confronted by hey you know you're
putting on some weight they're like oh
my gosh like i'm really sorry i'm gonna
go work on that